لليوم الخامس على التوالي يتواصل القصف
المدفعي والجوي التركي على سوريا يوم
الخميس استهدفت الضربات التركيه بواسطه
مسيرات مصفطه غاز ومحطه لضخ النفط في
الحسكه بالاضافه الى مناطق واسعه في
المالكيه والقامشلي حسب المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه اكدت
ان القصف طال ايضا مناطق حساسه في محافظتي
الرقه وحلب
فيها الجيش التركي في شمال وشرق سوريا
بهذا العمق وهذه المسافه منذ بدء الضربات
الجويه التركيه قبل خمسه ايام قتل 11
مقاتلا من مقاتل الوحدات الكرديه
يقول الاكراد ان الطيران التركي استهدف
بخمس ضربات قوى الامن الداخلي المسؤوله عن
حمايه مخيم الهول للنازحين السوريين في
ريف الحسكه الشرقي ما ادى الى هروب
محتجزين من عائله تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
اعتقلت قوى الامن الداخلي سته افراد من
عائلات تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه بينهم ثلاث
سيدات هربن في وقت سابق من مخيم الهول
كثره الهجوم التركيه على قوات امن المخيم
الوضع الامني والاستثنائي تحت السيطره
الان بسبب الهجمات
مع التحالف الدولي ضد تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه فيما تقول وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ان الضربات الجويه التركيه في
الشمال السوري هدد سلامه العسكريين
الامريكيين وان الوضع المتساعده يعرض
للخطر التقدم الذي احرز على مدى سنوات ضد
مقاتل التنظيم المتشدد